a descent into another world Bruce Lee
the self-styled king of Bucharest's
canals is going underground hey help me
out what did you do the ladder as the
pedestrians continue along their way the
group vanishes into a shaft on a busy
street near the train station soon we're
ten meters underground be careful it's
very hot don't get burned in the
Communist era these canals were supposed
to supply heat to the entire city Bruce
Lee takes us to his kingdom the world of
the rejected that has guarded the
hopelessly addicted this section
provides shelter to about sixty it's
estimated at least five thousand
homeless people live in Bucharest other
passageways lead to more makeshift rooms
the group is preparing to move to their
summer home above-ground it's far too
hot here now those who remain behind our
apathetic numb with drugs no one wants
to tell us exactly what is in these
syringes don't ask I can't talk right
now many of the homeless are addicted to
huffing paint the odour is everywhere
Bruce Lee sells it and has smeared it
into his hair it's popular with children
too a cheap high that numbs them if only
for a while
we want them to familie we're a family
here
were the dregs of society but we stand
by each other we want to get out of this
situation but the homeless shelters
aren't a solution for us
they're like jails how are we supposed
to find our way back into an ordinary
life for our children a family to find
work when we're locked up when they're
constantly telling us and forcing us to
do what they want Bruce Lee's arms are
covered in scars when he's high he often
cuts himself it's because of our
miserable life on the street or in jail
you know you don't do this when you're
happy or have a good life some of the
makeshift rooms are lit only with
candles others have electricity obtained
illegally from above ground the group
here has a strict hierarchy Bruce Lee
decides who begs for money and who gets
drugs many of the others also cut
themselves a sign of their desperation
and despair
I don't think about the future my life
is over the homeless near the train
station won't accept government aid the
shelters in Bucharest are virtually
empty even though it's free
only a few elderly people are here the
director of the local social assistance
office says the problem is being
exaggerated she says there are only
about fourteen hundred homeless not
thousands Jesse because I can't force
people to come to us they can earn more
from their illegal activities than many
people who work eight hours a day we
have to accept that in a democratic
society people can go where they want we
can't force them there's no single
solution that will work for everyone
without his bag of paint Bruce Lee won't
Venter a step above ground he says he
grew up in one of Romania's many
orphanages in the Communist era the
children lived in appalling conditions
hungry and neglected many poor families
were forced to give their children into
care
after the Ceausescu regime collapsed
that came to an end but that left Bruce
Lee to fend for himself many of the
homeless share that same history my
family abandoned me here at the train
station I think I was 5 years old I
can't remember
if the story that the staff here at the
ara s foundation have heard over and
over meanwhile they're struggling to
help the second generation the children
who were born in Bucharest's canals and
heating shafts most are hiv-positive and
many suffer from tuberculosis the
foundation distributes sterile
disposable syringes and condoms it's
important work but the state keeps
cutting back on their funding their
budget today is only thirty percent of
what it was two years ago sometimes it
all just feels hopeless everyone's dying
anyhow give me something for this
infection of my leg I can't help you you
need to see a doctor I told you you need
to stop shooting up in that vein the
next day Bruce Lee wants to take a few
homeless teens from his group to a local
cemetery a month ago one of the women in
the group was buried here Catalina died
of an overdose it's a big cemetery and
they can't find her grave or maybe one
of them says she's buried in a different
cemetery entirely four weeks ago they
were all here for the funeral but now no
one can remember where she's buried